anything can go wrong on live news the
hardest part of the job for those brave
souls who sit in the anchors chair is
remaining calm and collected no matter
what happens for the most part they do
an admirable job but occasionally their
emotions get the best of them when that
happens the results are incredible here
are some of the funniest flip outs from
our favorite anchors and hosts f-bombs
away after reporting on a story about a
medical marijuana business in Alaska
KTV a reporter Charlo Greene resigned on
the air now everything you heard is why
I the actual owner of the Alaska
cannabis club will be dedicating all of
my energy toward fighting for freedom
and fairness which begins with
legalizing marijuana here in Alaska and
as for this job well not that I have a
choice but wait all right we apologize
for that green later admitted that her
live spectacle was a ruse to increase
public support of medical marijuana
nothing changes conservative voters
Minds like erratic behavior in
connection with drug use right John
Brown versus the Kardashians a lot of
people dislike the Kardashians but John
Brown one of the anchors of good morning
Orlando took it to a new level
he literally walked off the set in
protest of a story about them he
couldn't help screaming his disapproval
from off-camera as his co-host tried to
quickly get through the segment okay I'm
having a good Friday so I refuse to talk
about the Kardashians today you were on
your own Amy I can't do it I had enough
Kardashians I can't take any more
Kardashian strains on this show he was
quickly replaced by another co-host but
couldn't stop yelling illogical Heineken
on stories announcer unfortunately he
just made the entire thing into a story
bigger than Kylie Jenner's lips
anchors miss bridge implosion a bridge
is about to be imploded this morning and
make room for a new bridge a routine
bridge implosion was the epic event to
WGN Chicago anchors were banking to be
the highlight of the broadcast after
waiting for several minutes for it to
happen they briefly cut away to the
weather guy of course this is exactly
when the bridge fell
the 30s around here aren't you a baby it
was played for laughs
but it was obvious they were
disappointed we'll do it live before he
screamed to people for all kinds of
reasons on The O'Reilly Factor Phil Oh
Riley screamed at the crew of Inside
Edition his freakout was for one very
specific infraction the teleprompter
during one of the most amazingly awkward
clips in internet history
O'Reilly is clearly running late for
something the teleprompter screws up
multiple times
uncorking the hosts full fury I can't do
it we'll do it live okay do it a lot do
it live I can Bob write it and we'll do
it live saying shucks
to his credit Oh Riley is still able to
snap right into congenial host mode when
he has to which makes him either a
consummate media professional or a
frightening sociopath either way
the clip is a classic Jim Ryun versus
Dick Oliver it's a live interview that
features a building manager and tenant
giving their sides of a contentious
construction project you'd expect one of
the interviewees to be at the highest
risk of a freakout but in this clip from
good day New York it's actually the
anchor Jim Ryan who tears into chief
reporter dick Oliver right so what do
you want now well if I have to teach you
how to be a reporter Ally I'll do that
later is there any question you'd like
me to ask her and no I'll give you
lessons on how to become a reporter I'll
give you some lessons and how to be an
editor because I was your boss once yeah
you were and are no longer how did that
happen it's an amazing peek into the
dynamic of a television newsroom and
aging media personalities Piers Morgan
politely flips in a prolonged debate
with two gun rights advocates Piers
Morgan desperately tries to get a single
person to agree with any recently
proposed gun control measures Morgan
fails miserably so what does he do he
gently crumples up his notes and tosses
them aside he
very nearly raises his voice as well
Morgan reserved his true bile for other
gun rights interviews however yeah I
know I know why sales of these weapons
have been soaring in the last few days
it's down to idiots like you there's
also a possibility that he later in a
clear sign of extreme displeasure serve
them tea with no crumpets whatsoever
Whoopi Goldberg and Joy Behar walk off
yep Bill O'Reilly made this list twice
only this time he's the one who keeps
his cool while Whoopi Goldberg and Joy
Behar walk offstage after O'Reilly's
remarks about 9/11 see their credit they
both came back after O'Reilly clarify
the statements it was still an epic
meltdown moment for a show whose entire
formula is built on people arguing for
an hour with the occasional cooking
segment thrown in Bill Maher gets
hands-on on Real Time with Bill Maher
Bill's job as host is to discuss the
highly contentious political topics of
the day so it's never surprised when
emotions run high
for the most part debates take place
among the panel guests not a debate
since wait between us you're in the
audience audience comes from the Latin
to listen but on one show protesters
from the audience were so disruptive
bill had to intervene hey do we have
some security enough or do I have to
come on
ouch sometime later Marv was heckled
again but at least Kevin Smith took
responsibility for the disruption dad
shut up thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which freakout
you think should have made the list